hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt ich
backe heute eigene leckere früchte tat
und zwar ist das ein mittig boden mit
einer frischkäse mascarpone
zitronencreme und leckeren früchten
obendrauf und sogar innen drin und ich
finde sie sieht einfach sommerlich
lecker aus es waren hübsch transmission
früchte ganz oben drauf ich fühle ich
loslegen ich auch wenn ich richtig lust
roper ich auch deswegen zeige ich jetzt
zuerst einmal den möglich und zeigt euch
das volk ist die zutaten für den
mürbeteig traurig 180 gramm mehl 40
gramm gemahlene mandeln 50 gramm zucker
100 gramm butter 1 ei gibt etwas mit
extrakten eine prise salz
ich nehme jetzt zuerst die butter und
den zucker und verrührt es alles in der
küchenmaschine ihr könnt den teig aber
natürlich auch mit der hand verkneten
einem klick ist es auch ganz einfach
gebe ich auch direkt kontakt mir dazu
unterzahl und sobald sich die zutaten
verbunden haben kommt auch das betreiben
und dann auch direct mail und mandeln
der teig sieht jetzt ziemlich bröselig
aus ich werde jetzt aber mit den händen
zu einer kugel zusammen formen
falls ihr jetzt aber gleich merkt dass
er zu trocken ist könnt ihr gerne noch
etwa einen es lassen kaltes wasser
dazugeben ausprobieren und dann jammer
ich warum ich sage ich immer wichtig
dass die temperatur dass die tat engel
zimmermann sind eure kühlschrank warm
oder kühlschrank kalt beim hybrid müssen
die zutaten kalt sein denn der mürbeteig
wird nur dann wirken wenn er kalt ist
und berührt icon zum beispiel ist es
wichtig dass die zutaten zimmer wahnsinn
damit sie sich eben gut verbinden und
dann lassen sich zum beispiel butter und
zucker besser aufschlagen
das merken kann und ich frage nächste
woche noch mal nach also ich merke jetzt
bei mir ist es ein bisschen gruselig
deswegen gebe ich noch ein bisschen
kaltes wasser mit dazu
die zutaten für den mürbeteig wann breit
kalt aber dennoch musste jetzt gekühlt
werden
dafür gebe ich ihnen erzähle in eine
schüssel reihen decken ab und stellt
dann von mindestens 30 minuten kühl
der teig gesetzt abgekühlt ich habe hier
bereits eine tanzform gerichtet und zwar
einen durchmesser von 22 cm und die habe
ich mit buck rem fray eingefettet
getreulich den teig dünn aus und zwar
auf etwa 26 cm dass er eben 4 cm größer
ist als meine form wäre dem ausfall
merkt dass der teig etwas zu bröselig
ist dann fehlt einfach noch ein bisschen
flüssigkeit gibt dann einfach noch mal
in vereinen teelöffel wasser mit dazu
das mache ich jetzt hier auch mal kurz
und ihr seid jetzt auch wie schnell sich
die konsistenz verändert hat jetzt
konnte ich den teig nämlich richtig toll
ausrollen
mit einer torte palette und gehe ich das
einmal drunter
da kann man den teig auch toll anheben
falls ihr übrigens einen einfacheren
teig machen wollte so der schweiz wieder
der 124
ihr könnt aber auch in 123 webtrekk
machen da ist die konsistenz schon von
anfang an etwas anders und etwas
einfacher in der handhabung aber der
hier ist einfach ein bisschen mehr als
etwas feiner jetzt lege ich den teig
über den rauswurf starb und dann direkt
in die backform
das ist hier gar nicht schlimm dass da
jetzt abgerissen ist ich lege die teile
einfach wieder dran drückt sie fest und
kann oben dann den weg nehmen
jetzt den teig mehrmals mit einer gabel
ein das sorgt dann dafür dass der teig
beim backen schön flach bleibt jetzt
fühle ich den tag noch mal für eine
halbe stunde und kann ihn dann backen
der abwickelte teig wird jetzt im
vorgeheizten backofen bei 180 grad ober
unterhitze für 20 minuten vorgebacken
und die zeit muss sich dann gleich um
die füllung herzustellen
während derzeit ist noch immer offen was
werde ich schon mal die füllung zu
bereiten das ist eine frischkäse
mascarpone füllung ich brauche dafür 250
gramm mascarpone 250 gramm fisch käse
ich nehme gerne philadelphia im doppel
ram stufe 2 eier habe ich auch das
eiweiß was vom eigelb teig üblich mal 80
gramm puderzucker eine bio zitrone etwas
an den exakt und hier habe ich noch 150
gramm gemüse früchte ich hab jetzt
erdbeeren blaubeeren und hingehen und
die brombeeren hatte murat vergessen die
hole jetzt gerade noch deswegen starte
ich einfach ich zuerst einmal frischkäse
maccarone und den zucker in eine
rührschüssel das könnt ihr natürlich
auch mit dem handrührgerät verrühren
also produkte kann auch mit rein dann
das ganze schön glatt rühren
und in der zwischenzeit hält schon mal
um eine lex zufügen und auf die schale
der bio zitrone abreiben und da immer
darauf achten dass sie nur den gelben
teil ab hat und nicht hinreißen
jetzt gebe ich die zitronenschale direkt
mit dazu
und dann wirklich noch die imitation und
ob noch übrig seien
jetzt wird alles gut verrührt
die füllung ist fertig und die last
jetzt hier einfach kurz stehen und kann
in der pfeife schon mal die erdbeeren so
ein bisschen klein schneiden
der teig ist vorgebacken und ich habe
ihnen so etwa zehn minuten noch abkühlen
lassen
jetzt kommt direkt ein teil der creme
mit rein so etwa zwei bis drei esslöffel
und der mozart hat übrigens jetzt keine
frischen bomben gefunden deswegen weiß
welche aus dem tiefkühlfach das also
auch nicht schlimm aber ich finde passen
farblich und geschmacklich super mit
dazu deswegen hätte ich schon gerne mit
dabei
kommt da die bären mischung mit drauf
die vermischung vorher gibt es auf dem
teller
o
jetzt denke ich die fähren mit der
restlichen creme ab die tat wird jetzt
noch mal bei 150 grad ober unterhitze
für etwa 40 minuten fertig gebacken ich
habe die tat nummer fünf minuten länger
gefangen von der konsistenz her sieht
jetzt so aus also in der mitte ist
dennoch nicht billig aber ich kann da
sie direkt raus nehmen
da sieht man es hier auch jetzt lass ich
die tat kommt stellt sie dann noch mal
für eine stunde in den kühlschrank und
dann geht es mit den früchten weiter
die tat ist abgekühlt und ich hatte sie
auch für zwei stunden im kühlschrank
denn sie lässt sich zum einen besser
schleifen und zu anderen schmeckt
einfach besser
ich habe die tat in diesem in dieser
form mit jedem toten
deswegen können sie zum auslösen muss
man nur die platte und unter noch
wegnehmen
dafür setzt er sie am besten auf eine
unterlage
und jetzt habe ich hier vorne noch mal
die ganzen früchte die ich vorhin auch
für die füllung benutzt habe
also heidelbeeren brombeeren adware und
himbeer und die erdbeeren schneidig ist
also die halbiere ich jetzt
und die früchte lege ich jetzt wie einen
schönen kampf um die tat heran
das ist nicht ganz ordentlich sein muss
schon ordentlich was ich finde ich
einfach irgendwie kunterbunt draufsetzen
u
um
ich habe die tat noch mit ein paar
basilikumblätter dekoriert man können
zum beispiel auch mitnehmen aber auch
basilikum passt wirklich geschmacklich
sehr gut mit dazu vor jetzt kann ich
direkt anrichten
muras darf direkt probieren sie einfach
also das ist jetzt echt sind und kuchen
den ich echt zu schade zum anschluss so
ein richtiger sommerlicher
sonntagskuchen der tat passt natürlich
wieder zum sonntag 20 15 tatort sonntags
gehört nicht gemacht zum tatort stellte
ein wortspiel genau soll man soll auf
jeden fall ein sehr scharfes messer
nehmen damit die torte bzw takt auch
angeschnitten schön aussieht silber
richtig ins zeug stück verloren aber das
liegt jetzt auch daran dass ich jetzt
stand mitten im link auch daran dass
sich die tat in seinem teller drin hab
weil ich das foto so schön fand aber auf
einer richtigen geraden platte hätte ich
natürlich schön schreiben könnte okay er
ist platte steigt mit runtergerutscht
auch so schneiden studio also hier unten
dieser vater mehr zeigt dann die früchte
die mit gebacken wurden
hier habe ich noch die leckeren und
obendrauf noch dankeschön so zeichnen
zuschauer hier das ist viel zu tun
das ist keine frische habe ich recht
eine möglichkeit die möglichkeit ein
handelshemmnis basilikum waschen
basilikum draufpasst so ok ich probier
sehen martins ein hochbeet grad nicht so
schön
das ist genial ehrlich und so spricht
geht es normalerweise macht also ich
würde schon genial dass kein rabatt drin
ist was ich sagen möchte aber wirklich
genial und ich finde man könnte es zum
beispiel statt der zitrone limette
nehmen wobei ich zitrone schon sehr
passend finde die reiswaffeln gehört
hier natürlich nicht mit den freunden
für gut befunden
super und das weiß ich auch super
also wenn man jetzt wirklich keine
frischen früchte da hat kann man auch
ganz gut gefrorene nehmen wobei man sich
dann direkt eigentlich verzehren sollte
denn die gefrorene früchte die town ja
dann auf und die werden dann ziemlich
schwierig da oben traf sie zum uns
merkel ja also falls sie jetzt auch lust
auf diese tat bekommen hat dann geht auf
meinem blog sallys - blog.de da stets
noch mal ganz genau und ich wünsche euch
ganz viel spaß beim nachhaken
ich schneide jetzt auch ein stückchen ab
und setzte nicht rauslassen terrasse und
dann lassen wir noch ein bisschen sonne
machen
bis zum nächsten mal tschüss und so
sieht sein haus
doch